[Music]
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
to tonight's uh speaker Abby Smith
Ramsey Abby is a writer and historian
focused on the creation preservation and
use of the cultural record in all media
she has worked with the Library of
Congress and the National Science
Foundation taught at Harvard and John's
Hopkins University and she's currently
the board chair of the center for
advanced study in the behavioral
sciences in Stanford short casbas who
are also our partners in bringing you
this talk tonight Abby's most recent
book out just last month um is called
memory edited Taking Liberties with
history after the talk Abby will be
joined here for Q&A by Rick prelinger
Rick is a an archist a filmmaker and
also a professor uh at the University of
California Santa
Cruz so now let's continue that Applause
and welcome Abby Smith Ramsey thank
[Applause]
you thank you very much I want to
welcome you all um I'm so happy to be
here at long now tonight we're going to
have a conversation about the past and
the future
and I want to ask the question which one
comes first does the future really arise
from the past or is it more true to say
that what we think of as a past arises
from how we imagine the future I don't
think it's a very easy question to
answer although it may seem that way and
I telling you we're not going to be
talking about Quantum Theory but we are
talking about the ways that people
conceive of how people feel the passage
of time especially in times of Crisis
which this is
is and how controlling images of the
past can be manipulated to control
people's future what will this
particular moment look like in
retrospect in 40 or 50 years what do we
know about this moment which will be
totally inaccessible to people in the
future and what do people in the future
know that we cannot know I think the
answer to that is pretty simple they
know how this will all turn
out I just want you to bew Ware that one
of the great flaws about talking about
the past is that it seems all too
obvious that things turned out the way
they had to turn out however if we were
to look back at this moment in 50 years
and and see how it turned out we might
well be completely shocked at how it
turned out so I want to keep that in
mind also keep in mind that nobody in
the past had any more certainty about
how things were going to go than we do
in the present so I say let's have
compassion for people in the past that
for example they didn't all the wonder
they didn't know all the wonderful
things and behave in The Virtuous ways
that we now do I talk about this crisis
because it's really an identity crisis
for this country acute polarization that
we suffer from now is a symptom but it's
not the cause of this crisis it's really
an identity crisis and I don't mean this
in the angsty teenage sense and I don't
mean identity politics either I mean in
the most fundamental sense we cannot
agree on who we are we don't really know
who we
are so who's America are we really
talking about making great
again and when was that time when the
country was truly great I think we all
have a different opinion about that and
some think that it never has been great
not their America in any in any
event you know this political slogan in
evokes something that historians are
very familiar with which we refer to as
a Nostalgia of Utopia or utopian
Nostalgia that is a longing for a past
that probably never really existed but
holds a very strong grip on our
imagination this political slogan evokes
some some time that was really great and
it was born of a fear of the
future and I can see why people are
afraid of the
future but the slogan itself allows
people to imagine things that they
wouldn't otherwise it gives them
sanction to imagine that there really
was a time that was great I should say
in the interest of fairness that Obama's
slogan was equally provocative and
hopeful his slogan yes we can also was
talking about a future that many people
were afraid of and meant to give
confidence but you can bet that it is
not the same future that people have in
mind so to paraphrase the Talking Heads
how did we get
here it's almost instinctive that when
we end up in a place we didn't expect
such as this place we have to look in
the rearview mirror to figure out where
we took the wrong
turn today when we search the past for
answers unfortunately we stumble into
the Bramble Butch of the history Wars as
a nation we simply cannot sort out what
our past is did we originate in
1776 which was the beginning of the
great experiment in Democratic
self-governments or did the president
day America originate in
1619 when Prosperity today has been
bought we realize at the expense of
other people's land other people's labor
and other people's
freedom I would argue that both versions
of this get it completely wrong and fall
into the fallacy of Origins the mistaken
notion that our Origins determine our
ends that is what we call history as
prophecy history is not prophecy the
Trump merch
this magar red hat signals not a set of
ideological beliefs but loyalty to a man
and membership in the warm embrace of a
tribe such behavior is mirrored equally
on the left to be frank which has its
own slogans its own merch its own trial
behaviors and which is often called
virtue signaling this polarization has
led to a bizarre loss of touch with
reality the last time I was saw such
departure from reality or to put it
kindly departure from a shared sense of
reality was in
1983 I want to note that all maps are
courtesy of the David Ramsey map
collection I was living in a dormatory
and my roommate was from the closed
military city of vasto which you can see
here 11 time zones away from Leningrad
and Moscow the first departure from
reality that was that vlasto was kept
officially on Moscow time not local
time she came back one day from from a
trip to the market a trip that took her
hours incidentally with a prize purchase
and that was a kilo of butter butter was
a scarce commodity even in the
well-provisioned cities such as
Leningrad Moscow and
vlasto she beamed with the pride of
someone who had just won the lottery and
frankly she had every right to gloat she
asked me how often butter was available
in our markets I answered always the
word always was so far from what she
could even imagine that she had to take
a beat then pulling herself up in all of
her dignified skepticism she said in a
tone somewhere between pity and
condescension that she understood that
naturally I was a patriot and I had to
defend my motherland but I did not need
to
lie when I protested that I wasn't lying
she grew indignant I had just confirmed
to her everything she had ever heard
about capitalists so what I took away
from that year in Moscow and Leningrad
was less about the the subject I was
studying and more my knowledge that in
fact those who control a population
sense of reality or their imagination
really controls them totally it they
control what they can imagine what is
possible and what is not possible in the
world for that woman more than a kilo of
butter in the market every single day
was simply not a possibility that was
Earthly at at
all my experience means and I take it
with me almost every day is that I look
at the present situation from an oblique
angle the better to see what's going on
in this country with In a Different
Light so in 2016 I first learned about
alternate facts I was alarmed what had
happened Trump ran in 2000 he talked
about running in 2004 he campaigned
without declaring officially in 2012 how
many people predicted that he was going
to live sorry live um when in 2016
I mean he told those same outrageous
lies all the time although they got more
robust over the ages what I was really
shocked by was the eagerness with which
our fellow citizens and they are our our
fellow citizens believed them to be true
or wanted them to be true or frankly
just needed them to be
true why is that well we'll get to this
but first I want to show you the kinds
of everyday hijacking of history that
the Soviets did which may be instructive
on the extreme right is Nikolai yof the
man who ran the nkvd which was this of
the predecessor of the KGB he was the
man responsible for conducting Infamous
purges of the
1930s oops he fell victim to the purges
himself so after he fell victim to the
purges there was a new version of the
future it was a future in which jov was
not Stalin's trusted comrade and frankly
had never been I wanted tell you that
falsifying evidence is as old as
evidence itself so here today gone
tomorrow am I saying to you that we are
at risk of doing something like this in
this country I mean personally I
wouldn't have thought that this brace
and manipulation of facts was possible
because after all we live in the land of
freedom of expression and the Press we
all Forward Motion civic education from
the early 19th century which is when
this timeline was done by the great
female educator Emma Willard inculcated
in us as Citizens that we were leaders
in the virtues of freedom and equality
at this point Americans were busy
defining who they were and where they
fit into the world this map told them
that they could look back and see that
their own place in history was extremely
short and abbreviated and they wanted to
become therefore the Vanguard of the
future but so did these men want to
become the Vanguard of the future here
you see lenon and trosy in 1920 in
Moscow marks and Engle said in the
Communist Manifesto Like Us in communist
Society the present dominates the past
and I'd say in truth it is the past that
more or less determines the present but
in our society it is always the present
that determines the past the Russians
took certain liberties with history to
bring it into align with with Marxist
theory and here you can see that when
trosky was expelled from the party in
1927 he also was lost to history or at
least he became an alternate history
even before Photoshop was invented it
was always easy to bring the past into
alignment with the present you know I'm
sure many of you have heard the joke
that Soviets and I think Russians
probably still tell which is the future
is certain it's the past that's always
changing the business of revising
history is very active these days and
not just in Russia not just in China but
also in this country as well I want to
share something with you from the
Memoirs of this spectacular woman nades
the mam here she was in 1922 when she
was 23 years old and married to the poet
o mam who would perish in the gulag
shortly after this time she happened to
be staying in the family of the family
home of Victor schlowsky who many of you
may know as the great Russian literary
critic here she's describing schow's
teenage daughter naria and here I'm
quoting from the Memoirs she showed us
her school textbooks where the portraits
of party leaders had thick pieces of
paper pasted over them as one by one
they fell into disgrace this the
children had to do on instructions from
their
teacher varia said how much she would
like to cover up commissar Nikolai soska
I mean after all we're going to have to
sooner or later why not now but she had
to wait for instructions at the same
time the editors of encyclopedias and
reference works were sending subscribers
most such Works were actually sold
through subscription at that time a list
of articles that had to be pasted over
or cut out with every new arrest people
went through their books and burned the
books of disgraced leaders in their
stoves when our Heating in the new
apartments which had central heating
instead of stoves forbidden books
personal Diaries correspondence and
other so-called subversive literature
had to be cut into tiny little pieces
with scissors and thrown down the toilet
as she said people were kept very busy
and this will explain Soviet Plumbing to
you so I say props to the teenage girl
who had a sense of humor about it that
said she was helpless to do anything
except cultivate a sense of humor about
it you know memory is a remarkable thing
and the way it can be manipulated for
good and for ill is quite remarkable
because of its inherent flexibility what
you see here is a cell from the
hippocampus which is the main organ of
memory in the human mind actually in all
organs Minds thankfully our nervous
system is designed to be flexible so
that it can learn about the world and
modify its understanding of the world
you see all the time we're learning we
have a little model of the world in our
brains which actually predicts what
we're going to see so that when
something is different we notice it
right away it's a very efficient system
of staying alert to threats and so brain
scientists these days actually refer to
the brain as a prediction
machine but that also means that the
brain to be efficient has to throw away
a lot of information it judges to be
irrelevant and unimportant and thus I
say that for a good memory forgetting is
a feature it's not a bug in short memory
is the raw material of ourselves as
individuals and as members of society it
comprises our identity in effect to
hijack history is tanam out to identity
theft and it is to my mind a political
crime crime whoever commits it you know
it's remarkable but nesa mam lived well
into her 80s here she's seen she's 80
years old still as fetching as ever and
still smoking cigarettes I don't know
what her magic was except this that she
was determined to survive she was
determined to survive remember and write
down everything not just her husband's
poetry which couldn't be written down in
her lifetime but also everything and to
teach us lessons to the extent that she
could although she wasn't very
optimistic about any body learning
anything from
history let me just again quote from her
memoirs which I think is really touching
for us these days the capacity of memory
both Collective and individual to gloss
over to improve on or distort the facts
is particularly evident in periods when
the foundations of society are
collapsing these disorders to which
memory is prey the tendency to embellish
or suppress awkward detail the need to
vindicate oneself show how dangerous it
is to rely on one's own conviction of
being right since this is all too often
based on false criteria our main task is
instead Define true
criteria there's also the problem that
while distorting our Recollections and
thus hindering a proper appreciation of
individual or historical experience
memory is at the very core of our
Humanity it is all that we have mandam
incidentally survived because she was a
woman women were not recognized as
political agents in the Soviet Union and
I dare say perhaps in Russia as well and
certainly in most parts of the world
women could be used as Weapons against
men as emotional blackmail but they had
no
agency so a little confession this is
not a portrait of NAD sham of course is
a painting by the great painter kazimir
malevich who I think properly depicts
what this kind of world looked like that
there were people who were made as great
prototypes in this case a woman farmer
but featureless she was just part of a
mass and absolutely featureless because
in fact she had no memory as mom says
the first task is to recovery memory in
all of its complexity the good the bad
the ugly and the Beautiful and to do
that we must start with the facts of the
case those are often very hard to find
even in libraries and AR arives and
museums especially if archives and
museums are collected in such a way to
slant information to record only that
part of history that we like that we
agree with or we think it's going to be
indictment of our enemy it's very easy
to plant information to be read later in
a way that's
distorted so a special plea to libraries
and archives which as you know are just
critical in this
moment you know I can't go into all the
complexities of why and how the Russian
state has decided to close its memory to
Outlaw its civilian Cadre of um
historians and to close the archives to
most
people but a major undertaking of
Putin's regime is to rebuild the Russian
State as a state that transcends history
in many ways or is old and sacred he
does this through the aggressive
rewriting of History texts you can see
this happening in China as well it's
happening in the United States on both
the left and the right but I think we
need to go far deeper than just getting
the facts of the case correct or making
sure that our history textbooks align
with the facts I think we have to move
beyond the model of history as the march
of
progress I think that's the main reason
we were so unwilling or unable to cope
with a Cascade of catastrophes that we
experienced in the last three decades so
what's happened to us in the last three
decades well there was Y2K which we kind
of skated past then there was 911 which
few people seem to anticipate including
our security agents then there was a
2008 financial crisis which was staring
Us in the face but nobody seemed to see
then we were kind of relieved when Obama
was elected and then shocked that Trump
was was following him then there was Co
19 then there was January 6th and then
there was Ukraine and unfortunately this
weekend we have the Middle East more
Slaughter more senseless death and the
reason that Americans have been caught
backf footed so many time
psychologically is because we're simply
not prepared to know how to deal with
catastrophes like this if everything is
all forward motion I'll note that we
face this dilemma over and over again in
our history and apparently we don't
recognize how familiar that is I'm
thinking in particular now about the
innovation of artificial intelligence
the promise and the threat before that
there was the promise and the threat of
social media which was still behind
dealing with and before that there was
the promise and the threat of the
internet itself still hard to catch up
with that and some of us remember the
promise and the threat of TV which seems
to have abated only because TV itself
has fallen by the wayside due to other
media there seems to be a reflex in the
American psyche that if we hand people
the most appropriate and upto-date tools
that they will always bring out the very
best in people and only that so why do
we so tenaciously cling to our belief in
our own innocence this is a point that
was made very well by one of the fellows
former fellows at casbas Jennifer
Richardson who wrote a wonderful essay
in the Atlantic Monthly about why it is
that Americans particularly white
Americans are surprised every time
there's a seeming setback in the racial
progress in fact it depends upon your
point of view we actually need to
believe that in order that we can move
on but it's not in fact true we can't
just be you know free writers on
progress you know as One True Believer
in progress said it's difficult to
predict the extent of self-government
that the man of the future may reach or
the heights to which he may carry his
technique social construction and
psychophysical self-education will
become you know two aspects of one in
the same process all the Arts literature
drama painting music and architecture
all will lend this precious beautiful
form man will become immeasurably
stronger wiser and subtler his body will
become more harmonized his movements
more rhythmic and his voice more
musical so does anyone recognize this
voice it was the voice of
trosky in case you didn't realize it
that Marxism Springs from the exact same
belief in the almost Limitless
perfectability of humans endowed as we
are with reason cultivated through
education and the ultimate product of
which is Tech technological that is
material progress Marx believed in the
ultimate liberation of humankind from
the constraints of nature the Bolshevik
simply wanted to speed up the process
but it's not a dream that is unknown in
this country as
well so if we don't believe in this
March of progress because we believe in
deep time now it's still all upwards in
Forward Motion you know we still believe
that it's all progress we have very
different views of human nature now than
did the founders of our Republic or
marks and Engles the pillars of their
enlightened vision of self-government
was reason we have to accept the
cognitive science not to mention
darwinian evidence throws shade on just
how objective human rationality can be
Scholars such as Daniel Conan also a
casbas fellow and Amos tersi have shown
that reason is often just a post Hawk
justification for decisions we make
through older non-rational parts of our
brain the ones that really are geared
for our survival that are tied into our
emotional instincts and to our amydala
further more Enlightenment views of the
compatibility of Liberty and equality I
can't say have held up all that well in
a nation as diverse not to mention
polarized as ours we have just to look
at the Supreme Court's docket to see
that one person's Liberty can become an
impingment on someone else's I urge all
of us who think that democracy is worth
saving and fighting for to think about
the need to reinvent it for the
Contemporary world we can't just rely on
Old views of human nature and old views
of how history unwinds itself so how
exactly should we be doing long-term
thinking now first I know that we need
to acknowledge the past without
believing that it is a tale of Destiny
we cannot conflate the past with the
future history is not prophetic nor is
history a moving sidewalk we don't just
step on time and it moves along whether
whether we hurry along or not it will
end up taking us forward in in
progress I will say that the past is
critically important as a Point of
Departure but probably nothing else it
doesn't foretell the future it is the
place from which we begin the rest is a
matter of contingency and chance and if
this map even though it was done in 1849
10 years before the origin of the
species was published if this map
doesn't foretell just how complicated
and fortuitous history can be then how
many strands are intertwined and how say
someone can come along in one line The
Thin Line at the top is that goes all
the way across as Alexander the Great
glorious conquered much territory but
didn't last long and the Roman Empire
which had many tributaries which have
died out and sometimes gone into very
interesting rivlets and strange places
we're presented therefore with endless
choices to be made without fully
understanding any of their consequences
and the faster we feel the the pace of
time the more urgent we feel the need to
make decisions without considering the
consequences and again I urge that now
particularly at this moment we step back
and not just reach for ready solutions
to the problems that we face and
certainly not reach for Comfort when
there is little Comfort to be had except
through well assuring ourselves of
things that we can assure ourselves
about so this is why my message really
is that in the absence of this certainty
the one thing that we need to be crystal
clear about is the moral foundations of
our
decision and that's not very
easy so what do we do with history what
do we do with the past Socrates
reputedly said that an unexamined life
is not worth living I don't know I mean
I know plenty of people who don't
examine their lives and seem to be very
happy but I but I will say categorically
that the unexamined past is
dangerous so what are we supposed to do
with the statues of say Confederate
generals and other public art that
reflects views that we now hold to be
anathema are we supposed to just destroy
them destroy evidence they existed
should we take a hint from the Russians
who' have actually rounded up some of
these statues and made a park out of
them the Russians love parks and this is
outside of Moscow and there's evidence
of the past there's also evidence of
revulsion against that past you'll
notice that Stalin is missing his big
nose you know the defamed statues the
defaced statues are here so people can
see both what was believed and also how
people refuse to believe it you know I
talk about knowing the truth but how are
we supposed to really know the truth if
as mom says we should always question
whether we are right or
not how can we even talk about what we
think is real when nowadays reality is
kind of all triggers all the way down I
suggest that we keep in mind the words
of this man chadv who had the
distinction of being the first Russian
to be called insane because of his
political views hence the name of his um
last missive the appal loia of a
Madman he said that love of the
Fatherland is certainly a very beautiful
thing but there is something better than
that it is the love of
Truth so how do we know the truth well
we test it we test it by talking to
people that we completely disagree with
here some of you may recognize this
debate that was held in 65 between James
Baldwin and William F Buckley you can
see how old it is you could you should
definitely look at it if you haven't
seen it it's available on YouTube and
all of its grainy Glory it's spectacular
in fact it's harrowing especially from
this perspective so just as there is
tension as I say between freedom and
equality there's also tension between
the production of truth and the
production of national identity this is
inevitable in a country like ours
and it should be frankly to me the fact
that we're fighting over history is a
very good thing there are plenty of
countries in which that we are not
allowed to fight about history this to
me is what democracy looks like this is
outside the Supreme Court after the do's
decision you'll see women of about the
same age some of whom are elated and
some of whom are in despair I think it
is a category mistake to see the do's
decision as a step backwards because
history doesn't move backwards it only
moves forward or moves along just as it
is a mistake to see that Trump's
election was regression it actually was
just the next stage in an ongoing
struggle we have we didn't solve the
problem of racism by electing a black
man sending the decision about how to
adjudicate the rights of the born and
the rights of The Unborn back to the
states is again the next stage of
Engagement it's another chance for us to
work out the differences in a way that
we have not been able to as long as we
were fighting about a roie
Wade so because I really want to be able
to talk with you and hear your questions
and talk with Rick my grand Inquisitor
let me close on this note no no I I love
the grand Inquisitor he's one of my
favorite characters in fiction um let me
close by saying that long-term thinking
requires radically new temporal framing
not a March of progress not the end of
History you know we live in interesting
times we don't know how things will turn
out but pay attention because if we
don't pay attention and if we don't
participate other people will decide for
us thank
you thank you Abby actually like to talk
a little bit about the truth to begin
you state in the book that civil society
and civility itself begin begins and
ends with the shared acknowledgement of
the truth that sounds pretty idealistic
now doesn't it and earlier in the book
you state and I love this quote uh
historical truth is antithetical to
narrative satisfaction this runs counter
to the incessantly repeated cliches
about storytelling where we hear that
stories make us human and that
narratives help us create uh patterns
and meaning you're not saying that
you're saying that narrative
satisfaction takes us away from Truth
where does storytelling take the wrong
Fork where do good stories end and bad
ones begin well I will say that if you
tell history as a as a narrative you
have to adhere to the rules that Frank
Cod mentioned in one of his books which
is a narrative to be satisfying has to
have a beginning a middle and an end and
that the end has to harmonize with the
beginning you can mess up the middle as
much as you want and again I don't think
there are endings in history I think
everything keeps moving forward and I
think the most productive way of of
thinking about it one which actually is
liberating is that what happened in the
past is a place of departure it is not
the end I do think that as people are
claiming space for their own identity in
nowadays they mistakenly refer to my
story telling my story and that means to
me it connotes that one can shade some
of the things that don't fit in with the
narrative and I always object to the
roughing out of the bad details or the
good details I mean I think history is
full of the good the bad ugly and the
Beautiful so you have to get all of it
or it isn't realistic I think that in
terms of fiction you can you know really
helps to have a narrative and that
narratives can tell truths through
fiction that are as profound as history
but they're not to be mistaken for each
other I also find it interesting Rick
and maybe you do too that in the 20th
century certainly in the modern era
after the catastrophe of the first world
war there was a rejection by most
artists of the idea of a narrative that
could make sense of anything in fact
they wrote in an anti-narrative way
because the world had ceased to make any
sense that was their way of telling the
truth so it's interesting to me now that
storytelling has been
revived I'm not sure that it's
appropriate in every case and I think
history is not a case where we should be
telling
stories yeah and we're seeing a bit of a
backlash there was a great piece by Peru
seagull uh in the New Yorker um again
sort of the tyranny of narrative and I
noticed today in the New York Times
reviewing the the films at the New York
Film Festival that what that writer
found uh remarkable is that the the
films were letting narrative go and
focusing on experience but again
experience is is complicated too um I
I've never been called the grand
Inquisitor but um sorry no that's
awesome I I I I feel like I have a new
job well he was the one who got the
truth out of Ivan karamazov so yeah yeah
um so look uh what I really am is as an
uncredentialed archist and you are a
historian uh who for much of your career
has worked with libraries and archives
how have memory institutions taken
broadly served the cause of maintaining
and Pres preserving Collective memory
and how have they fallen short how
should memory institutions adjust in
this time of of what you call Source
Amnesia and the spread of disinformation
yeah well I do find it interesting that
many Librarians and archists think that
um that their personal judgment about
the nature of Truth and history affects
their collecting when I've always
understood at least from an historian's
point of view I want archives and
libraries to be full of authentic
evidence um and I can't imagine a world
in which a historian would make sense of
the of you know the past if there were
only one flavor of things I mean I think
one of the things that people are
noticing and making actually a big deal
about is that the archives that are
created by the people in power um
actually have these what are called
these absences and so we need to fill
them in what seems to me that if people
collect according to the political
preferences they have which I can see in
certain libraries then they're creating
their own absences and I don't really
understand how they can justify that I
understand why but I just think it
doesn't serve the profession let me just
give you an example after the breakup of
the Soviet Union there was a brief
period of time when yelson decided that
he was going to open up the archives it
was a way of discrediting his
predecessors communist predecessors
including G off and so for a brief
moment of time the Communist Party
archive was opened for example and when
I was working at the librar of Congress
the librarian of Congress Jim Billington
persuaded the um yelson to open an
exhibition of those materials in
Washington and then they would go to
Moscow where where there would be on
display it included Stalin's party card
but it also included and this I give
verbatim in the book A really atrocious
um directive by Lenin in 1920 to go out
and and so round up a couple of hundred
people and hang them high basically as
an example and it's the most disgusting
kind of language um and uh and yet it
was in the archives it was in the party
archives so I was talking to the Russian
archist saying it's remarkable that all
this stuff was kept she said we kept
everything and I said how did you feel
about that and she said well first of
all it was our job and second of all I
always hoped this day would
come
and that really moved me and that's
actually I mean after that incident with
my with my roommate and several other
people like that in Russia I thought
that it was one thing to be an historian
but there but at least one person in the
profession should actually be caring
about the way that the source base is
made and that's why I dedicated my life
to spending so much time with libraries
and
archives and yet you know people often
ask me uh aren't you worried about all
these films that are getting lost aren't
you worried about everything that we
can't save and I say while we shouldn't
intentionally destroy things that loss
is actually formative loss uh a
perceived loss of History suppression
censorship destruction of knowledge
leads to the new histories that have
Emer has led to the new histories that
have emerged in the last 40 or 50 years
loss can be formative in the same way
that archival absences can speak louder
or loudly as presences true very true
yeah the gaps on the shelves tell their
own story and I I kind of haven't worked
that through with regard to some of the
things you say in your book but i' I'd
like to suppressed histories
uh you know have a the US moved towards
a racial Reckoning in 2020 or at the
very least it gestured in that direction
suppressed histories moved closer to the
foreground there was a moment where it
seemed that in the in the conventional
press that we were seeing some
sophisticated discussions about race as
a discourse and as a system of power but
we're now seeing a disturbing reaction
on many levels um you suggest a shared
sense of reality based on the real as a
nation are we capable of that are we
capable of confronting our history and
accepting or moving towards a shared
sense of reality
oh yeah I think we are I mean I think
that we need to commit to it but I do
think that well we have to but I do
think that we're capable of it of course
we're capable of it I don't think
there's now here I'm going out in a limb
but I don't think that there's been an
appropriate call to leadership I think
the people who enter public life
now are are the ones who uh want to
disrupt they want attention and I think
the whole the whole notion of public
service except in some areas has been
widely discredited and that's what I
think is the real shame that and of
course what all of us probably agree on
which is we need better education for
people you know grades 1 through 12 to
teach people how the government works
it's no surprise that people of a
certain under a certain age you know
that have never seen Congress pass a
budget for example um all 12 bills um or
seen people working across the aisle
have they have no reason to think the
government can accomplish something so
why would they go into public service
and I mean specifically the government
but I I think that we can turn that
around we certainly have in the past and
it's my Ardent hope that we can I also
think that there's I'm not deterministic
but um there is something about the
demography which is going to settle a
lot of issues for us I think myself and
some people in the room will not see
that will will not live to see it but
we'll be gone and more people of mixed
race will
come into being in this country and that
will seem normal to them and they will
find other things to disagree
about I mean as a professor at Santa
Cruz I've seen the future of California
and it is bright uh there's no question
about that look I've I have one more
question for you and then we can we can
open it up um this is a terrible time to
lose our Collective memory preserving
Liberty equality and democracy and
protecting all of us from Universal
threats like anthropogenic climate
change and maybe nuclear proliferation
these require us to act mindfully and
quickly where should we
[Laughter]
begin I mean does doesn't this room call
for call for Big
Ideas yeah I was going to say you first
no but um okay well actually this is um
it's a big idea it's not going to be
easy to um address but I honestly think
that the biggest problem um in our Civic
life in our public life is the role of
money and too much money and it's
infected politics I mean you know we
could talk about income inequality I
think that's a reflection of the way
that we have distorted the role of money
in this country my understanding of
American history and I'm not an American
historian is that the founders wanted to
put into place Financial incentives
because they were so much against the
royalty and Aristocrats and the church
so copyright was not was something that
was to counter the Monopoly of um the
church and um you know royalty over
publishing so you know money kind of
inadvertently started to become this
linga franka and I think that since we
don't seem to have an appropriate amount
of Shame about accumulating vast amounts
of money anymore that seem to have
gone by the way um that it's really hard
to regulate and I also know that you can
make a lot of money in this country
without going into the most important
professions such as nurses firemen
teachers you know state senators that
kind of thing you know those are those
are those are loser professions in in
some people's measurement and it's just
how can people think of that so I mean I
don't know how we're going to change
that attitude but I think that that's if
we get at that then I think it's going
to begin to solve or at least unwind a
lot of the tightly wound things but it's
a gordian knot and I don't know how to
cut through it I don't have that sword
your book is an excellent start and uh
and I commend it to all of you um I'd
love to open it up for uh questions um
yes you have the mic I have a mic is it
on there we go uh so my question is
about um staying present or the
importance of presence as we go through
time hearkening on your last question
I've been living through we've all been
living through predictions about 2050 in
climate change and we're now halfway
there since paying attention to it at
least for me since thousands so you know
our our our presence in time as we go
forward through things we're predicting
or seeing in the past is uh you know an
experience we have in life so I I wanted
you to expand a little bit on this this
how do we ride paying attention in the
present as a as something you brought up
that was important and how does that
evolve over time as we live through our
lives and and watch things unfold well
the present means something very
different for you know a six-year-old
than it does for someone who six
and what I really mean is that instead
of thinking that somehow we're going to
solve this problem in the future that
hasn't gotten us very far um and so and
I want to impress that every day whether
we know it or not we're making decisions
that affect not just our future our
present and future but other people's as
well so I think to the extent that you
can widen um you know your FOC your
focus and see um how your actions can
ramify then I think that staying in the
present is a pretty good thing the
future it seems is always being
foreshortened and as you go through life
um it seems actually to get further and
further away it's paradoxical um and I
also think that there's way too much
emphasis on in our consumer Society on
replacing things not investing in things
that um that last for a long time as it
was in the old days um and also that we
we pay too much attention give too much
Credence to to this cry that oh time is
collapsing time is faster and faster oh
we're losing our attention span no we're
not losing our attention span it hasn't
changed at all there's a lot more
competing for it and I don't think we've
yet learned how to filter and control
the things that are competing for our
attention but I think that's a unint a
natural side effect of all new media I
mean if you can go back and read the
stuff that was read about written about
printing you know it's just it's it's
make you cry with laughter it's so funny
so and their lives were a lot shorter
than ours um that also changes the
perspective a lot I can't I I can't
possibly speak to the issue of why we
haven't done enough about climate change
but that's not what this talk is
about uh thank you yes I I really
appreciated how you talked about um
yearning for pushing past Grand
narrative
and wanting to get into the complexity
and the richness of History uh could you
maybe spend some more time on that
perhaps Illuminating some examples where
not researchers and academics but like
the general population like at a
national level actually engaged with
events or history like in that complex
richness that we're
seeking I'm not sure what you're looking
for R.J but I will say that Anyone who
reads a really good biography will begin
to understand the complexity of a single
life if it's a good biography um you'll
be able to understand all the things
that all the the situation that a person
is born into is sort of given um the
constraints of their you know their
gender their family um mean the time
period they live in I mean I often think
about what it would have been like as a
woman to be born even a hundred years
before it's kind of unimaginable I don't
like thinking about it um but um but I
do think that biography is the clear the
clearest representation of complexity in
history and it's all in one it's in one
book and it's in a person who is made to
be in who is intrinsically interesting
and a good biographer will will reveal
why it is intrinsically interesting it
doesn't have to be a great person it
could be you know um there are some
wonderful biographies of women in 17th
century New England based on their own
diary
so you it can be a humble life but it
can show you well it can really tell you
how complicated things can be I think
public history the practice of public
history and community history also can
uh can help uh very sophisticated
engagement with historical thinking
there were some there's a question here
there's a question here and there's a
question
there um so you talked a bit about like
gaps and gaps in a history where things
are just missing but one thing I've
noticed um is there's also gaps where we
don't know how to interpret things
perfectly or less perfectly some of this
is literally just language that's the
easy example we don't know the language
but sometimes it's even for stuff like
just as recent as like 100 years ago we
might not know the slang we might not
know the reference people when write
when people when are when they're
writing stuff down they assume so much
context um and as a historian who spends
a lot of time with work done by
archivists what is the kind of how do
you think we can be better at this for
future for the
future better at representing the
context you mean yes better at um
represent better at including context
with the material so that it may be
interpreted from someone coming from so
far in the future that this context may
have deteriorated entirely yeah you know
I'm sorry to say that you actually can't
um one of the things that I mean you can
write a history book which has a lot of
context it will be very long but it will
be wonderful um but you know I have to
say as someone who studied medieval
Russian history you know there's
learning the language there's learning
about all the sources that were around
there's trying to get at the fact that
they didn't write about anything but
lurgical and Court Affairs you know you
can become conversent in a culture and
look at the gaps and be able to
interpret interpolate certain things but
never with any certainty so there's a
lot of sort of theorizing or a lot of I
should say
hypothesizing um but the past is really
gone and what's left is what's left I
have to say the greatest Boon to history
um in the past I'd say 50 years is the
advance in Material Science the fact
that there's so much about inert
material um entities you know soil and
things like that they can tell us so
much about the context in which Stone
Age people lived for example I mean you
can pick up any Journal um any issue of
science or nature and you'll see some
breakthrough they've been able to
analyze the DNA of certain soil and see
where the you know where the ruminants
were and in fact find a little smidge of
DNA from somebody in in Asia but
actually this is in Scotland how do they
ever get there so I mean in that sense
it's constantly expanding but it's at a
scale which isn't exactly what I'm think
you're looking
for let's take two more questions
um this this is a a question maybe for
both of you um if you take the broad and
strokes and looking at even Material
Science and our current technology which
makes multiple copies of most things
would you say that on average that the
percentage of things being archived is
shrinking or is it enlarging over time
other words are are we headed towards
where fewer and fewer percent of
everything made is being archived or are
we generally headed towards uh a world
where more and more of the world is
actually being
archived um I'll I'll take that first um
first of all there's just an incal
incalculable amount more being inscribed
to begin with to being recorded so um in
that sense it'll always be bigger as to
how much of that I mean the present is
just creating way more information than
ever before sort of promiscuous amount
as to how long it is going to be
preserved I think that depends upon how
well we how good we are at preserving
digital information how long and what
percentage of all everything being made
what percentage of everything being
made Will Will Survive I'm sorry but we
will survive oh I mean obviously there's
the more is being produced the more
that's going to be captured at least in
the short term so is the percentage of
of the STS being captured growing or is
it shrinking so capturing so I think I
see a distinction here Capt caping being
fixated in some form or another um that
isn't archiving uh that just means that
it's been captured so I take a picture
of Abby with my phone uh it's probably
not going to outlast uh my phone or it
won't Outlast Google so I think uh never
has so much been captured never will so
little be
archived it's a good one that's a quote
there um yeah I wish I'd said that I
will I will I will quote put you on that
yeah thank you so much for your and yeah
last question do you have any
recommendations for practices that we
can adopt into our lives to help build a
sense of shared reality with people
around us uh yeah well I'd say the first
thing is um find some people you know
whom you respect but really disagree
with and get to know them and talk with
them and that be I mean you know you
want to have somebody that you can
respect because you want to be able to
confide you don't want to feel afraid of
having a conversation with them you
don't want to feel censored by them or
judged by them um but you also have to
listen to them as closely as you expect
them to listen to you and so if you can
somehow you don't have to reconcile your
views but if you both understand what's
at stake um in your views why you arrive
at the at the views you have then you
will literally have a shared sense of
reality you will um you may not agree
but you will at least least um at least
get beyond the that's ridiculous how can
you possibly believe that you know
you'll
understand thank you Abby for everything
let's let's have a hand for Abby Smith
ramsy thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you